and I now have the great pleasure to
introduce to you senator sam Brownback
senator brownback of Kansas born in a
small agricultural town Parker and now
the last eight years the Senate
representative for the state of Kansas
but his interests are not just Kansas
his interests are the defense of the
vulnerable the unborn the persecuted
throughout this world and in his
chairmanship of the subcommittee of the
Senate which looks at our foreign
relations with Korea with China with
Japan senator brownback has shown
knowledge and commitment to the people
of Korea the career freedom act is his
bill he introduced it he led it into law
the Korean broadcasting is his idea and
his leadership to carry through he has
shown commitment to the people of Korea
and to those who suffer still in the
camps and prisons of North Korea and
senator brownback has gone beyond career
he is the chairman of an organization
known as the u.s. Helsinki Commission
which was created 30 years ago to bring
about closer cooperation in europe
between the former Soviet Union and the
NATO allies and in his leadership of the
u.s. Helsinki Commission he has held
hearings on the rebellion or revolution
in Kyrgyzstan the causes of revolt in
was becca stan the roma
the gypsies in Russia and in our own
country he has looked at the trafficking
in women in America this is a man of
both moral clarity and extraordinary
courage here's a man who's willing to
take on the soft thinkers those who find
an easy way out this guy stuff this guy
says I will confront the appeases I will
confront them with Christian commitment
to love my neighbor and so I have great
pleasure in introducing sam brownback
very nice make a fun day
thank you very much negroponte a and
what a great pleasure and what a great
lady let's give her a round of applause
miss Negroponte a thank you and thank
you for all your commitment her her
husband has served in a number of jobs
for the United States government and she
has as well in a various set of
positions of things she's done thank you
thank you thank you for all of you being
here today we're here about freeing
people in North Korea we're here to talk
about freeing people in North Korea and
what needs to take place and people
should be free everywhere in the world
including and especially in North Korea
agree that needs to take place and many
of you have been long time people
advocating and working and praying for
the freedom of the individuals in North
Korea and it's important that we do that
it's important that we confront this
issue and it not be set to the side that
the discussion of human rights for North
Koreans is a front and center issue not
a sidebar issue that it's one that
should be part of the six-party talks
it's one that should be front and center
and not shuffle to the side and we'll
hear today from a perspective of an
individual who was involved in earlier
talks against an earlier regime where it
was important that human rights was a
front and center issue to be discussed
before we get to the panel though I want
to recognize some of the individuals in
the audience and number one of those I
would like to recognize and have stand
and have you recognized any and
everybody in this audience who was in
North Korea and has left that country I
would like to invite you to stand that
we could recognize you individuals that
were in North Korea and infected from
that country and here
over here
that that takes extraordinary courage
and commitment to do that I was on the
Chinese North Korean border a couple of
years ago and it is a very difficult
situation for North Koreans that are
there you're going to hear from an
individual that was in one of the gulags
in North Korea today I met him several
years back before he was famous in met
President Bush i had read his book the
aquarium's of pyongyang before the
president didn't get near the stir but
when the president's read the book
people started taking notice I would
commend it to everybody it is an
incredible book you also have one of the
long time advocates for freedom and
human rights and and a person who has
lived it that's going to be on this
panel and I'd like to introduce each of
them separately to you our gifts today
our natan Sharansky and can qua juan and
i'd like to have both of them come up to
the stage at this time and i'll do a
more full introduction as they come up
among the many gifts received by
President Bush I can't think of any more
important than our two guests today they
both met with the president recently as
his statement and his work for freedom
for individuals around the world these
two guests are survivors as are those we
recognize from the audience who have
survived the regime in North Korea
innate on we have someone who survived
years in the gulag of Siberia of the
former Soviet Union and Kang someone who
had a much younger age who is ten I
believe when he entered the gulags in
North Korea is today also a survivor of
a brutal system of gulags this one in
North Korea I want to personally thank
both of these heroes of mine for being
here today and for never giving up on
the fight for freedom while they are now
free they continue to fight for those
who are not free the chains of those
that are in bondage continue to rub
against their skin as it should continue
to rub against ours because none of us
are free until we're all free
I can truly live in that purity of
freedom until we know that everybody
lives in the pure air of freedom so I
asked you to each as they come up to
present what I'm going to do here is ask
for each of them to make a short set of
comments and then we're going to have a
dialogue back and forth to welcome and
to greet them and first I would like to
bring up mr. natan Sharansky please give
him a round of applause
well thank you yeah chairman no new
friends and their friends I just how was
speaking tears come out and sausage
don't have too much to ask but as you
remember when I was speaking I was all
the time quote in one book not my book
but this book acquaintance of Pyongyang
because I really was surprised when i
read it was so surprisingly how to to
see that different nations different
cultures different histories but the
nature of fear the mechanism of total
return until aterriza cream is the same
to destroy the desirability people to be
free to control them by fear but also
the mechanism of resistance the
mechanism of getting rid of this tyranny
is the same that's why I believe that
it's so important while speaking about
the lieutenant dream of North Korean and
seeing it as part of this Empire fear
which still exists which is shrinking
becoming smaller but still exists in
North Korea in Cuba in some countries in
the Middle East in some other place and
no doubt it we people of the free world
and especially people of the free world
could you what it is to live in fear
society we have unique experience but
also unique obligation to help to those
who are still this prison to get rid of
this please we are very glad that we
have such good and strong friends in an
American Congress and American cells but
it's very important that the leaders of
the free world will hear our message and
will we will make sure
that policy of appeasement policy of
adjusting our world to the needs of
dictators will be stopped and that we
will force dictators to adjust their
policy to our ideal freedom thank you
thank you nate on I was always taught
that in the dealing with Eve or you
don't negotiate you confront it's not
something that you negotiate with i went
to next bring up can quaff one is the
author of the aquarium's of Pyongyang
and who would have thought is a
nine-year-old boy that he would be sent
to a North Korean gulag and to spend
over ten years there he spent that in a
concentration camp but who also would
have thought that after ten years there
and coming out and being able to leave
and get out of North Korea that he would
then meet with the President of the
United States and to be able to tell him
about his experiences in the nature of
the regime in Pyongyang and so I asked
you to give a hearty hero's welcome a
Joseph type welcome if you will to Kang
qua anh
such a civilian again candle on him
drink tuna with Cinda to outside the
hotel in tomorrow wouldn't the way I
provide the way provide done Tom Seaver
being loaded onto the floor Oh child hey
give us aw jeez al rato Lorenzo de 13 de
una ventaja Cinda look uh take a
terrible world had a sentence Hamelin
honky-tonk singular I'm to negate Runa
rotten c'mon entrando yoga's Andre
compulsory una vez pasada chignon tomomi
choice humulin queda Jonathan de a treat
on pourra hostility a minute remove our
seats Helena put it on Padre in coral
Viennese a career in and a frantic on
Lucinda gone on ginger chicken chettinad
easy man hog way even younger in general
Donovan po che ha my mom doesn't sing
about honda what's a good circuits Ron
Thunder Rasengan teacher saw a demon or
rookie blue shirts in NJ so that's some
nice him down many surprising things
many surprising things many surprising
things have happened in my life of a
blade back when I was nine years old I
was a slave boy I was a political
prisoner and since then I have escaped
from the cool bag and came to South
Korea and became a reporter and not too
long ago I had the honor of interviewing
the president of the United States
however when I had escaped from North
Korea I had a hope my hope was that I
would one day become the voice of those
who have died out in the gulag those
people who have by whose with whose
death I have witnessed however for many
years over 10 years my hopes never came
to fruition in particular because the
help there was no help from the South
Korean government
this was about their people this was
about their brothers in North Korea
however the South Korean government
never did anything to help us in
particular when the issue of North
Korean human rights came up in the UN
for three times South Korean government
had refused to participate or to help
and personally I think this was like the
e1 young who had sold South Korea who
had sold Korean Peninsula to the
Imperial Japan just like that Oh soon my
pension skills to eat able to go or
conduit hi Lucinda bitte it's
hillwalking saw cousin come home at dawn
go buddy its kind I'm done mmm compost
Vegas hands London could talk to some
Congress on Damien give her a bow tie
his hands and run dr gokal para Bonin
told October la hija de san antonio so I
calm down when I'm done chicken balloon
would eat a min boo boo Thunder God
coaches a loser I'm doing Kim Jong a
jump own a tune got empty prob she was
open to Oshawa now hi have a number you
don't instigate o rly door the current
hey get em young so the loop pleading
with Rome varaha boyz in da seen an held
onto an epitome CEO pennant 21 to
consume in the same moon torn up as a
call in cannes our own charity wasting
done you know the human circus isn't a
virgin de echar agua de y sweeter from
wawa as excited to present chiquito
ortog a minute on de Cinda you don't
look like a double [ __ ] you Lucinda I
have read the famous book by mr.
Sharansky and in the book I sure this
line with you that people who are living
in the taro regimes they must have
braveness within their heart and also
those who live outside of the terrorism
they must have the ethical discernment
to be able to tell one from the other
now I speak to the people of Korea and
also people of the world that the
appeasement alone is not in
when it comes to dealing with North
Korea the sunshine policy of South
Korean government had gone on for eight
years and during that eight years we see
that the lives of sad lives of the dog
Korean people have deteriorated and also
their human rights are being violated
even more as of today and also there's
the issue of the nuclear warhead that's
mushrooming over our head now these are
the results of the eight years of
sunshine policy we know that it has gone
awry I think it's time that we corrected
soon vago 8am you get a binge on don't
hit turns into a battle Muslim engine
Doha when done through mundo John
Yolanda wooden bow por aqui moon so Andy
minato seems almost on him don't worry
go banham to endure so much on you ha
well he don't want drama law gingerman
time did for evolution alameda preval uh
so I attention generate only go kim
young-shin see though the contagion see
what is anyone over to do kundo chunk
hamsa hand out ago oh honey colander yes
not get to manage the gay consented to
me I have but utmost respect for the
people who have worked and fought for
the democracy in South Korea and who are
continuing to do so in this new
government of South Korea that includes
Mr Kim moon soo assembly member and also
cook young son Reverend and also there
are many people who I know who have been
fighting for the democracy of South
Korea and who are continuing to do so in
South Korea and also there are with us
today our Kim Jung soon and Kim taejin
who had suffered together at the gulag
in North Korea with me and thank you for
all of you who are fighting for the
human rights of North Korea
thank you thank you going to have a
discussion here will just remain seated
during this this part of the program if
you have particular questions I don't
know if we're going to have time or a
format to be able to do it but you could
write them down and try to catch one of
the staff members from Freedom House or
that's working on this to pass them up
and we'll see if we can get to some of
them what I'm going to do is ask
questions of our tube panelists and then
see as much as we can to to take place
Stransky I'm going to start with you if
we could you've you've seen this action
before and you as I take it recognize
what the North Korean government is
doing from what you saw the Soviet Union
doing when you were on the inside of the
Soviet Union and you're in the gulag
what what were some of the most
effective things that people did on the
outside to advocate for change within
that Soviet sister well first of all it
was be clear we Soviet dissidents would
not survive even one day if there was
not constant pressure of the free world
if our struggle was not also struggled
all the bigger role and when I was in
prison I was an absolute isolation I
didn't know what's happening there in
outer world but from the behavior of the
KGB guys for defect from the secret
police for the fact that each time when
I was close to death they were
retreating and world meeting our demands
me and does a distance was the best
proof there under the pressure and what
this measurement displeasure meant that
the leaders of the free world were
linking their policy their economical
assistance military assistance trade
agreements loans cultural agreements
everything linking with the equation of
human rights for us the best day in
prison was when we read in Soviet
newspaper the article condemning
President Reagan that kick old Soviet
Union evil empire and white it was the
greatest day for us in prison we
we are so excited knocking through the
most buy mores and communicating in
other ways from one cell to the other
telling that finally the leader of the
free world called the suede suede said
the truths about Soviet regime and it is
very important to stand the moment the
free world the leaders of the field
start speaking with moral clarity
calling that this dictate data should
stir Easter dreams by name or his
present rate and said I'm not innocent
he told me present Reagan later I when I
met him after I was released from prison
he told me I am NOT interested to build
friendship with Soviet Union as long as
Soviet Union's the prison for its own
citizens when this is the policy of the
free world then we have a coke and then
recovered future are we are we the
United States I want to ask first and
then secondly the broader world
community speaking with enough moral
clarity regarding North Korea well I
think not first of all as long as this
regime exists it means that we don't do
it enough enough you will do whether
they will stop with this but no doubt
there there are some very clear strong
voices and there is a lot of appeasement
a lot of desire to find a way to make
them less dangerous to make them more
friendly let's first talk about
reunification let us talk about some
security threats and let's postpone our
discussion of the equation of human
rights and we can see the signs of
appeasement from southern from united
states often from europe and the unit
from south korea we can see these signs
of appeasement and i think it's very
important that's why to take a very
strong moral position understanding this
model position also is the best for our
own security and it's clearly the best
for the North Korean people and human
rights and there's no doubt it that's
what Korean people North Korean people
it those who say that those Korean
people like this regime like to be in
prison as as our hero today that's not
the trace isn't to believe that there
are people who like to be tortured just
hang you you spent years in a North
Korean gulag can you give to the
audience so a story that summarizes what
your experience was like in that gulag
system just a vignette a brief story
about what would describe what it was
like living there o sanam te hará name
is epic Aneesa tomorrow jessica rizzo
O'Hara boudin te Moni a Sunday because a
sunstroke a yoga Cinda yo doc see you
soon to gay cookie okay sunday hunter 1
1 John tons of Iranian a mantra hana
yori mo na lang KO heap o Shahi temp
ryokan yummy mahavira one-on-one date
Cambodia's nagar omega marañon since
oxygen on hotels in arlington bodeguita
nadiya ke momentum over the question the
Arakan sony support relevant since I out
how a cinder well I I was sent to the
political prison because my father my
grandfather in fact was a political
prisoner and I was a third-generation my
grandfather so I was guilty by
association so at a young age I was sent
to the other political prison and this
yo dog clipper prison the other gulag is
divided into two separate parts a one
party is completely controlled so there
is no access in or out and then the
other part is called a revolutionary
region so this part was somewhat less
controlled and this was the part that I
was in now the people in the completely
controlled area they I would assume
their lives had been much worse than my
experience who had been but I would not
know
and I would have not be able to tell
about it however I was in the
revolutionary region tintin film
Sorensen jin jang yi-jeong Coney 20 to
move to get some dahana noon honda
patrol kanya can't allocate region
Chicago Kosar on Durazo chessani senior
chickasaw choctaw yoshiki Manzo to new
single tragic human ecology is open y
daga mandram go to a yoga asana Terran
tampoco lo acabo de Japan to Connie
ocean gentleman conjugate 1c super igual
chinko didn't wanna jog win wasn't out
of the films like eternity she does know
Kim jong-il uses his gulag for the
following two purposes the first purpose
is to purge his opposition's and the
second purpose is to have these
opposition's work for his regime so Kim
jong-il would provide the list food to
the people in these gulags and these
people would be working for Kim jong-il
until their death and because of the
existence of such gulags even though all
the eastern eastern european countries
have collapsed north korea is able to
continue and with their own regime and
also have a generation change in the
dictatorship and Kulak serves that
purpose cutolo and return to ask me to
films resin on volunteers children do
totally psycho humans are umbreon
terremoto casa saludo y 3 mil go Todd
sorry hissing de Picardie conceived
under casa SI lo unnecessary dance man
auto pou conjuring doc from do tomorrow
chicken Hawks are old hat on tujunga
cochina panjagutta one consumes ah geez
you got a one and A Callahan assumption
mandando a chunky hungry panjagutta man
chua nada wat robo Chavo cool suits our
own hair is awesome de
Hitler he'd had his Auschwitz and he had
his gas chambers for mass execution no
such gas chamber he exists in the gulags
of North Korea however there is the
systematic starvation and forced labor
that led to the death of many people so
this type of systematic execution in
North Korea i would say in the last half
a century about 200,000 to 300,000
people had been executed in such a
fashion good seriously who knows how a
co she trained artist film soliton
couldn't film Jonathan was a checkers
and my university go you don't want a
garage a Madonna zone soon triangle
mother synergy 21 days though general
dosages how eager you films rob cg b so
how much for doing activities in ham so
we are at 21st century and we are still
hearing and witnessing that such cool
acts as the one that had been ran by
Nazi Hitler exist in this world and I
think it's about time that the
international community came together
and had one voice and to talk about
democracy and freedom and to talk about
such democracy and freedom without
discussing such kulaks as the one
existing in North Korea would be
ridiculous you can I'm going to ask you
the same question I asked mr. Sharansky
what would be the most effective things
that we could advocate for we had to get
change in North Korea for the people of
North Korea
chicken pecans on corner hey girl young
as oh puchis icon gaurav oh there was a
crunchy mandiri tracewski no no tengo tu
lado para para Linden de coches hi
rahegi tequesta ma devonian to consider
que no se SI non pas de tu mundo para la
fin de que llevar a comedian colleen
doran encantan october cylinder teachers
Herrera Hector hagas man heck pedazos
neon in commune general worden to carry
on tango tabuchi arena oooo ahah channel
a cool chokin condom yawn come young
kukunin rupiah Narvik Ebsen de la in
konoha dandenong bodensee onii-chan GTA
go code again sorry I'm Nagi hi Stan hi
deceit and run accident onion cuando
tienes up top that's like a pro teams in
the lambda well the North Korean regime
is using nuclear and the nuclear threat
to blackmail the world and also that
brings about the solidifying of the
people of North Korea and if the word
continues to focus on nuclear and
nuclear issues only I don't think we can
actually get to the reality of changing
the regime the changing the nature of
the North Korean regime I think we need
to talk about human rights first and
then nuclear later if we were able to
talk about and Link the human rights of
North Korea with the eighth and other
dialogues when it comes to North Korea I
think we could bring about changes in
North Korea and I think it's important
for North Koreans to come to realize
that all the age and support would be
suspended or stopped if there is no
discussion of human rights and once they
come to realization of such they would
come to talks and they would there would
certainly be changes want to ask the
same question to mr. Sharansky for i do
i want to note a couple of things number
one this is being broadcast live over
voice of america and the timing was
picked so that people in north
we could listen to this it's I
understand maybe one in the morning or
so and it's one of those times when
perhaps the guards are a little less on
on attention and people candless in this
broadcast so this is being live
broadcast into North Korea and a second
one is I want to recognize ambassador
mark palmer that's sitting up front best
poem would you stand up this is a
gentlemen if I could have him who's
advocated and has a bill moving through
the house of moving us towards a series
of policies that tolerate zero
dictatorships around the world if I
could put it that way and how many
dictatorships are left in the world 45
and counting down 45 and counting down
they're still way too many he was one of
the bold advocates during the Reagan
time of advocating for democracy
throughout Eastern Europe and a very
aggressive fashion again you don't
negotiate with evil you confront and you
confront and deal with the problems but
you don't negotiate mr. Sharansky what's
the most effective things you've
mentioned about moral clarity from the
rest of the world that we could do these
days to advocate human rights changes
inside North Korea well though when I
could immediate with resolution in the
best possible time what is the one
advice don't you give me a certain
presence I told you personally put me in
a very difficult station because they
have any advice NASA Kivar but if to
choose one I said speak to the
dissidents make it clear that America is
on the side of dissidents and not on the
side of the table by the way this
believe the fact the president of United
States of America and the last one sees
was all the time making clear that
America is on the side of people within
Iran in Iraq in Egypt
area in North Korea is extremely
important it's observable there will
never be 1 million people demonstrating
in Lebanon if it wasn't clear to them
that American on their side there was
never 4,000 judges in Egypt who sent a
letter to Mubarak demanding change of
Elections if this change would not have
i'm sure the defect that mr. Kent met
with the President had direct influence
might be even because of this North
Korea grid on the meeting of cigs
because they understood that now the
emphasis is moving towards human rights
so better wait let's make sure that it
will not be the station so these type of
demonstration not simple solidarity but
the fact that dissidents they are our
partners and not dictators something
what is really changing situation inside
I was speaking in my lecture before
about double sinkers and the multiple
thing is to encourage double sinkers to
become dissidents that is the way to do
but the way that is the way to do it
also if it is supported the same time
but clear policy in economical relation
political culture Helsinki agreement was
until now unique example how big group
of nations agreed to have a special code
over relations where human rights will
be connected and linked to own
international policy we still don't can
such type of code heck about North Korea
about the number of other countries and
that's something what is very important
to do sure those are good thoughts have
we seen over the last 10 years what
could be defined as a genocide within
North Korea numbers that I've heard up
to 2 million people died of starvation
or in gulags that's nearly a tenth of
the North Korean population and talk
about a weapon of mass destruction
that would seem to be here look well
when I'm thinking about this starvation
North Korea the closest what can come to
my mind is the installation of
Ukrainians in Stalin's Russia which was
part of the policy when Stalin decided
that he needs less Ukraine fine he
organized mass installation the fact
that here it is the regime which hates
its own people should not surprise it
because that's normal station for
dictators when feel themselves insecure
and when feel that the people are
becoming more and more critical to this
regime no doubt if you look what's
happening with the station what's
happening with these awful cramps and
that i read this member i he'll cut some
other things about this public capital
punishment skill of the people and of
course here we have to be very critical
to ourselves and to the countries who in
fact assistant to this when china is
sending i don't know how more than
hundred thousand people probably will
send from china to north korea korean
under the pretext that they have their
own demographic problems china was 1
billion people as demographic rollin to
keep some tens of thousands of fifty or
hundred thousand koreans and they are
selling them for death for their scams
lately so they just director since
assistance to this policy of genocide
and it should be not only condemned
where the free world has to make it a
very important point in all true
relation to share should we call it a
genocide in North Korea yes we can but
it's not enough to call it you have to
treat it as a genocide it's a good point
Hank
hang there's been long a perspective
that the North Korean people support the
Kim regime that they have been
brainwashed that they know nothing
different but that he provides
everything for them I want to read you a
statement from a North Korean who has
left the country's living outside the
country but he says he says this about
the North Koreans perspective of Kim
jong-il all North Koreans except for a
few who lost their souls and those who
can never be forgiven by the most
generous people do not look up to Kim
Jung ill any longer he's saying the
North Korean people do not look up to
Kim Jung Yeo any longer is that true
commodity to tottenham danke to the
ticket or check out toccata no tantalum
Lucinda johannesson their composure
sounds random from San Antonio naranja
whatta a contribution & some Sun God das
a pen on gchat pony named also ego some
computer boot all costa rica holidays or
Angela en del day Peter Sagan Dramani
Mahama azumanga kapoor khan whatever
balloon y como tiene en todas en el agua
en de cuatro Pogue animoto da quello che
a snowman wats man comprar otro symbian
channel kuya kim jong-il pego coy modems
bindry considerar people are cause you
all coaches a kangaroo
that that is a true statement I agree
with that mr. for mr. shanks Trask is a
book there is a passage where he talks
about that people who are living under
terror regime they would be leading
double lives on the outside they would
show loyalty to the regime however on
the inside they would have their true
feelings however these true feelings
would be hidden until they feel that it
is safe for them to become more honest
and when they are outside of such
terroristic regime then people come more
honest so as to the North Koreans on the
outside it would seem that the North
Korean people are 0 in 0 variance and
worshipping of Kim jong-il however once
the Tarot is lifted I think except for
Kim Jong Il everybody else was the
critical of Kim jong-il what would be
the most effective way that we could
communicate with the North Korean people
today different proposals have been
floated of how to get information
contained to a broad cross-section of
North Korean people how would you think
would be most of her please ah amigo con
son Dakota feminine gay gatchaman
chicken poo khanacademy you ponder and
tingly toes under them like a tumor /
talk to Tyree tango quranic as Draghi
today elderman to hamburg a trauma k
totally humiliated us all Mankins even
true he attack on Quinlan day you guys
have a lorry go to continue matera
chillin contended i was in the bottom de
come on genuine [ __ ] alone entire JJ
oil me down a gentleman Pocoyo and Elly
Pocoyo tangos intermittently chanson de
hungrily KBS's high gear pump in a Tonga
the RFA attended on very shaky cam song
in some dank you to him that a challenge
or gate and Oh God Cesaro has all chick
is over
on da moon the could you go to move at
tonys all the hundred times that i
don't--all police union return I look I
can't she did one of the continuity RCW
integrals there are quite quite a few
ways of doing that and first one would
be through China in fact I know we on
the outside here of China as being an
ally a major ally of North Korea however
I think China is also a major threat to
North Korea because the wind of freedom
comes through the border with China for
example soap operas made in South Korea
they would be going to China first and
then eventually find their ways to North
Korea so that would be one way of
effective communication with people of
North Korea and the other one would be
through broadcasting system such as the
KBS korean broadcasting system or the
RFA radio free asia because the people
of North Korea have come to realization
that the media used by the North Korean
regime is contaminated so they no longer
trust the media of North Korea they
can't rely on outside media more so if
we were to use these channels more
effectively I think we can communicate
with them more effectively and also
another way would be for us to drop more
radios in North Korea so that people
would have a chance to hear this
broadcasting more easily I want to make
sure with my organizers here that we're
where are we on time frame no it's time
or do we need to wrap up okay ladies and
gentlemen you have in front of you two
of really great heroes of our era it
always amazes me how out of a world of
billions of people a few come up to the
surface and then become symbolic of a
much greater group of people hundreds of
thousands in the Korean gulag and in the
Soviet gulag maybe millions I don't know
millions in the Soviet gulag and yet two
names stand out in that group certainly
mr. Sharansky and mr. kung are two of
those names that stand out
of individuals that have gone through
the hardship that have lived there and
now give voice to these death camps and
what happened there and remind the world
not to let this continue to go on to not
let it continue and I hope all of you if
you haven't read aquariums of Pyongyang
that you will and then once having read
it that you will not stop at that it's
not enough to declare something a
genocide action must follow it's not
enough to declare a regime evil action
must follow and remember it's our voices
that will probably keep many people
alive that's been true throughout
history whether it was in mr.
Sharansky's case or in others it's the
voice of those outside so that the
government itself is fearful of killing
its own people because of the
repercussions around the world and even
a regime like Kim Jong Il's fears those
repercussions so become educated learn
find out what these heroes of the era
have said and have done and become an
advocate against this evil please join
me in giving them a wonderful round of
applause for what they stand for do
thank you gentlemen and
I was good to join you